the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
good evening people I want to continue
our discussion of the end of the studio
era the advent of the kind of much freer
more independent more politically and
even morally liberated movies that
appear after the Hollywood dispensation
has subsided but remember that I've also
been suggesting to you that even though
that is there's a certain sense in which
a kind of artistic freedom was now
granted to directors and to an end to
American films and on balance I think
most view most dusk folks look most
scholars and film buffs looking at the
1970s would certainly share my sense
that it's a very remarkable decade but I
think they might also share my sense
that the film's had given up more than
they realized
certainly more than they were conscious
of that the shift in them in the in the
what we might call the media ecology of
the society which enabled this level of
freedom for movies also carried with it
a tremendous cost and remember how
decisive the numbers are I've mentioned
them a few times in this course at the
height of the studio era two-thirds of
the country is going to the movies every
week it's an habitual experience for
most Americans both adults and children
really by the time this system comes to
an end after in this by the time the
movies have been as I've suggested
several times in the course supplanted
by television as the new central
storytelling system of the society by
the time that occurs at the end of the
60s most Americans are going to the
movies only once a once a year and it's
only particular subcultures teenagers
for example who make a regular habit of
going to the movies and a good deal of
the triviality and superficiality of
movies of the eight of many of the box
office successes of the 80s and 90s from
the American film industry is a direct
function of the fact that the audience
had dwindled from the whole society to
particular subsets of the society and
the consequences the consequences for
the nature of the movie sense of its
connection to the society are powerful
or profound well we're going to explore
aspects finally our final exploration of
aspects of this topic comes in tonight's
lecture and especially in the exemplary
early 1970s film McCabe and mrs. Miller
that we're going to screen for you after
my lecture I want to begin by talking a
little bit about Robert Altman's career
and I'll actually look at certain
specific films and say a few things
about them in a minute
but first let me talk about what I take
to be some of his not only the only ones
but some of his defining qualities as a
director signature features of his work
the first and most obvious to me is what
we might call his moral skepticism he
really is in some respects
temperamentally
an outsider and it's interesting to
speculate I think about what might have
happened to Robert Altman immensely
gifted natural filmmaker had he been
born a generation earlier and had
actually to struggle with the
requirements and responsibilities the
confinements of the studio system but he
luckily for Altman he emerges in a time
when the tyranny of the studios and also
the creative input of the studios has
long has disappeared has gone away and
and and in that sense in that sense he
represents a new kind of independent
spirit yeah in filmmaking and and he
resembles some of the other directors
who come of age at roughly the same time
directors some of whom I mentioned this
afternoon like Scorsese or Coppola or
Alan Pakula a second and so one of his
defining qualities there's a kind of
moral skepticism a kind of sympathy we
might call it which is connected to his
what we might call his sympathy for the
marginal over and over again in Altman's
films we focus on either marginal
figures you know
movor reluctantly or inadequately part
of a larger community or we focus on a
community that itself is so dubious as a
community so damaged as a community so
enfeebled and unlike the traditional
communities that it's as if the
community he treats itself the societies
or groupings that he finds interesting
are full of are also in some deep way
non-traditional communities and in fact
in McCabe and mrs. Miller most of the
supporting cast were literally members
of a community of the counterculture the
ballot that is sung by the by the great
balladeer of American singer Leonard
Cohen in the beginning of the film would
have struck knowledgeable viewers as a
deeply subversive gesture because think
how often the Western begins with a with
a with a ballad with someone singing
ballads if you know the stories of the
West have become so mythological that
they're part of our song tradition our
musical tradition which is true as well
as our narrative tradition and many many
classic Westerns begin with a with a net
with a ballot of some kind The Searchers
has such a ballad in fact as I as I hope
you noticed
well McCabe and mrs. Miller begins with
the ballot as you'll see but it's a
subversive ballot it's sung by a man
Leonard Cohen who's deeply associated
with marijuana with the with the
counterculture with striking out against
Authority with writing anti-war songs
and there's a kind of countercultural
ambience a kind of countercultural
skepticism and sympathy for the margins
in nearly all of Robert Altman's work a
third quality or so his moral skepticism
then could be said to have at least two
dimensions one is a cup what we might
call an aesthetic dimension in which he
is skeptical about the inherited
strategies belief systems and even
structures of earlier movies and he
actually we in that sense an
aesthetically subversive whole but very
subtly so as I hope you'll see in
tonight's film he'll very often give you
a film that seems on the surface to
sustain and to recreate
eight all the classic conventions of the
genre in which he's working and it's
only when you look a little bit more
closely that you realize that although
the structural elements are there they
have been perverted or inverted so that
so that they have in some sense enacted
some kind of moral migration and stand
for virtually alternative beliefs
assumptions or values from what they
might have what from what they normally
are taken to stand for in the classic
genre films on which Altman is borrowing
or against which he is engaged it in a
kind of makind of mockery or or at least
hostile action of some kind I think that
McCabe and mrs. Miller demonstrates this
very dramatically although most of
Altman's films have these qualities in
some degree the second quality of his
moral skepticism is what would be not
now related to his true to his aesthetic
principles to his filmmaking practice
but would be more broadly as associated
with his with his with his politics with
his general ideological view of the
world and even there especially there
may be Altman styled himself a rebel
even when he was successful in Hollywood
in his early in his early career when he
was so mash was a box-office success and
in the in the period of the night of the
decade of 1970 through 80 is probably
the richest decade of Altman's of
Altman's career and and and and in that
time even though Oldman was very
successful and later he fell into
disfavor with the Hollywood bosses and
he spent some period of his career sir
underground in a way not either not
making movies at all directing plays in
various places or making documentary
films other or private films that were
not released commercially then he makes
he has a resurgence later late late
before his book before the end of his
life that lasts 10 or 15 years of his
life far again successes involved
successes at the box-office
so so the the second aspect of his moral
skepticism might be a kind of political
skepticism and a skepticism a political
skepticism both against the Hollywood
system and then against the larger
political structures of the society now
remember his subvert his political
subversiveness comes at a time when many
honorable and normal people including
your professor were subversive in some
sense because it was a time when the
country was at war in a war that many
people in the country thought was
unreasonable and wrong many people went
to jail or tour or protested the war and
Altman was on the side of the anti-war
forces he was on the side he was on the
morally skeptical side about wars and
about Wars of choice in foreign foreign
environments so he was both politically
and culturally a skeptic and
aesthetically a skeptic and both
qualities show up in his films in all
kinds of remarkable ways I've talked
about how that leads to a kind of
sympathy for marginality for the
condition of marginality and for
characters who belong on the margins of
the society who live on the margins and
he loved to make films often about about
certain kinds of human communities
subsets about human small versions of
human society comprised entirely of
misfits and marginal characters he had a
great and it's a so and he even has a
sympathy for what we might think of as
unconventional appearance so that you
know many of the actors and especially
the secondary background actors in his
films might actually be in in ads for
grotesquerie he loves the grotesque and
he often and and at least his background
characters often have a sort of
grotesque element in them he there's
there's a there's a love of the non
treat the of the of the of the weird and
the strange in Altman that you can feel
in his in his films and his casting and
in his subject matter another aspect of
another thing that I would identify as a
kind of defining quality for Robert
Altman is the relation in his films
especially as mature films between plot
and character there's a tendency in them
it's an aspect of his skepticism he
doesn't like structures that control him
and from one angle if you think about a
buzz
storytelling or narrative the plot is a
kind of controlling feature it
especially if you allow the plot to take
to take the foreground of the to assume
a position in the foreground of the text
the the plot can become a kind of iron
hand controlling the choices the
director maker makes controlling what
can happen to the characters and what
certain forms of action-adventure what
happens next the sequence of events and
the visual excitement of watching those
events is virtually the only interest
you have in such in in in film those
totally plot oriented films tend to have
stereotyped or flat characters in them
but all men even when he embraces
certain genre principles that require
what looks like a conventional linear
plot is what often tries to subvert the
linearity of his plot there's a kind of
digressive or or or dissenting nonlinear
tendency in Altman's work you can sense
it in McCabe and mrs. Miller although it
doesn't emerge really totally fully
until later in his career especially a
little bit later in his career the
fullest embodiment of this non plot
principle of this preference for
character over plot I think is probably
the film Nashville in 1975 in which you
see an image in which Altman displays an
immense range of characters to us and
skips from one character to another to
another there are certain centers of
interest they seem to have no connection
to each other and you sit there in the
film when the film first came out it
actually elicited a number of negative
reviews from reviewers who were angry
about the fact that it that the film
took virtually its whole length to make
clear that in fact there was a
connection between these characters the
complaint against the film was it was
plotless well that wasn't exactly true
it wasn't plotless in fact all the lines
of the plot do come together toward the
end of the film but the truth is that
elopement is at least as interested in
digression as in as he is in linear
linear progression and there is a sense
in which his films like to pause and
savor what's going on around them and if
you as you're watching McCabe and mrs.
Miller one of the things
you might ask yourself at a certain
level is what's this what's what's the
true line of the story I mean and in
fact it feels when you're watching
McCabe and mrs. Miller as if it doesn't
have at least a conventional Western
plot as the film goes on you begin to
realize yes there is the story here is
about the growth of this town it's
really the it's really in that sense the
film the film really is a founding myth
an ironic mocking founding myth but
there's a long while you're watching the
film you're interested in McCabe and
you're interested in some of the other
minor characters in the town but it's
hard to identify what the actual subject
of the film is at first well Ullman
likes to leave his audiences in a little
bit of confusion of that sort and he
doesn't like to say he doesn't like to
satisfy the narrow desire to have a
clear linear plot he he prefers some
principles of digression and one of the
reasons that he does apart from the fact
that he wants to savor the experience of
the world and he he's attentive to so
many aspects of experience that he wants
to often bring all of them into the film
he's very interested in sound for
example in this in the in the way sound
operates in the world and he does odd
things with his soundtrack as you'll see
in McCabe and mrs. Miller I'll come back
to this in a minute his preoccupation
then is with trying to create a
situation in which character unfolds and
he'll always sacrifice what might what
what a what a more action-oriented
director might think was the most
important thing in order to explore
character more fully then one can say
that one one very broad way of dividing
narratives as I may have suggested
earlier in the semester to you is a
distinction between plot driven and
character-driven stories and one of the
things one can see happening in Altman's
film again it's another marker of the
fact that Altman is operating in a in a
cinematic environment that no longer has
the conservative aesthetic constraints
that are placed upon a consensus system
so he can explore these kinds of
possibilities more fully than that or
can explore them at all in fact it's in
some cases he couldn't even have looked
down these territories look look down
these pathways if he'd been a
conventional
studio director so-so a distinctive
feature then of the way he works is this
tension between plot and character and
the M and the emphasis that that Altman
will almost always put on character the
way he even subvert your interest in
what is going to happen next sometime in
the film and as you're watching McCabe
you might sort of think about that
what's you don't ever feel that the film
is flagging you always are interested in
what happens but after a while you
suddenly realize that you're not being
carried along by the momentum of story
itself in the way you are in a normal
film in Orion of what you would think of
as a conventional film and McCabe is
only a minor version of this as I say
Nashville is a much more dramatic is a
much more dramatic instance of this
finally another distinctive not unique
but distinctive feature of Altman's work
and this occurs especially powerfully as
his career continues it's part it's
really a kind of you can sense it
earlier but it actually becomes a
dominant topic later in his career after
he's very successfully as great
confidence in him by the end of his good
last decade of his life he's conceived
of I think as a kind of master movie
maker and he finds it very easy to get
people to appear in his films and that's
where this principle comes in most fully
he's interested in me in blurring the
distinction between fiction and reality
and there are and and in fact in some of
his films I think Nashville is the first
one in which this happens and then he
returns to this this trick or this
strategy much later in his career in a
whole series of films in Nashville there
are some performers who are playing
themselves they're not fictional
characters some of them if some of them
are famous singers and so forth and they
they they appear as themselves Nashville
is about the American music scene and
also about the turmoil of American
society in the 1970s and so many of the
people who will put many of the people
who appear in the film are playing
musicians singers and suburbs
songwriters performers but there are
actually some real performers who are
recognized by the audience because
they're relatively famous who play
themselves well this mingling of this or
this blurring of the distinction of the
difference between fiction and ray
this this mingling of fictional with
real characters becomes a very
distinctive feature of Altman's work
later in his career and very quickly
then what I'd like to do is show you a
list of some of his films you can put
that up now Gregg and I want to say not
something about all and this is not a
list a full list of his films and you
can see there's a long interregnum of
almost a decade where he makes some
films I just haven't bothered to list
them this is not a complete listing of
his films although I think it is a
complete listing of his films made in
the 1970s and I did that partly because
I want you to see what a prolific and
productive decade this was for Altman
but also because I thought you might be
interested in seeing how many titles
register with you even if you've not
seen the films you probably have heard
of some of these films because they're
among the most innovative and important
films of the second American films of
the second half of the 20th century I
want to say a couple of things about
some of these films you've already seen
the ending of The Long Goodbye and you
know what a deeply subversive version of
the detective genre that film is I want
to say a word about California split
because in some ways it's a film that
most fully embodies this principle of
being interested in the marginal
California split as a gambler's movie
and Elliott Gould that sort of shuckin
and jivin and figure of anti-heroic
irony that you saw at the end of The
Long Goodbye is the star of California
split as well and almost the entire film
of a large part of the film actually
takes place at the racetrack and in
gambling environments the the climax of
the film is a trip to Las Vegas where
our our hero has a tremendous run of
luck you know nearly breaks the bank and
and California split follows the
fortunes of these two gamblers it's hard
even fully to follow the court of the
chronology of the film sometimes you
lose sense of how many how much time has
passed there are many things about the
characters that are vey get on and
unclear it's also a film parenthetically
show you've got kind of this is a
trivial detail but it's always struck me
as a mark of of Altman's perversity
every woman in the film
named Barbara I I especially noticed
this because my wife is named Bob but
it's all I think the perversity had to
do with Altman's idea that he could I'm
creating a kind of slice of life movie
thieves like us is a particularly
characteristic Altman feel not only
because it has a kind of plotless
amorphousness to it when you first look
at it even though it it has great
excitement and a great emphasis on
character and a great emphasis on
marginal weird people who sort of are
not solid citizens in any way but it
also carries another signature feature
of Altman's work which I did not list on
on my outline and that is he was very
prone to allow his actors to improvise
when they got in front of the camera or
not literally when he was shooting but
they would improvise work something out
no he didn't work from a set script or
he would allow departures from his
script very that's one very simply and
quickly one of the reasons he loved to
work with with Elliott Gould was Elliott
Gould was a particularly gifted
improvisational actor and and there's a
kind of authenticity in the performances
in most of Altman's films that partly
come from the fact that he was deeply
interested in trying to create an
illusion of authenticity that was much
more intense and much more compelling
than what the traditional Hollywood
movie offers he really wasn't interested
in the in the fancy lighting and the
very and and the very elaborate
patterning of the Hollywood film there
was something he liked grit and dirt and
and imperfection and you can feel these
elements and in his work and you can
especially feel it in the often in the
performances of his of his actors who
loved working the ones who like working
with him really loved it because it gave
them a significant creative at a part in
the film itself Sofia seems like us
there's a relatively minor Altman film
in certain ways but it shows his
interest in character his lack of
interest in plot and his love of the
marginal and of the and of course of
improvisational performance I've
mentioned Nashville already maybe I
should say a little bit more about it
simply because it really was an
unbelievably influential film
the film seemed to desert conventional
plot and and it almost in an arbitrary
way for its first-half simply to look at
various characters who had musical
ambitions and were bound for Nashville
that was sort of the only through line
in the film everyone's going to
Nashville but man and you really
wondered as you are watching the film
what could these characters possibly
have to do with each other will they
ever come together should they come
together and it's a very artful film in
part because of the way it plays with
the readers frustration about a about a
linear plot and then and in fact the one
of the things one of the things the
movie does is it makes you aware as a
viewer of the of the extent to which a
linear plot is a kind of crutch you lean
on when you're watching a movie it helps
you sort of get through the film if
you're confused about other stuff you
always have that sort of through line to
grasp onto and when Altman takes that
away from you or seems to take it away
from you he immerses you in the in the
moral texture of his movie in the
psychological and political meanings of
his movies in a way that would not be
true if you were fixated on what happens
next what happens next what happens next
I want to say a couple of words I've
mentioned Buffalo Bill and the Indians
to you earlier and it's one of his most
subversive westerns it's interesting
that he went back to the western genre
in this very creative period of his
career and I think one of the reasons
was he understood that there were
aspects of the genre he hadn't made [ __ ]
made enough front of there aspects he
hadn't quite destroyed or he hadn't
quite ruined all the sacred truths to
you a fuse a phrase but I'm going to
refer to later when we look that I have
on my outline for McCabe and mrs. Miller
so he wanted to return again and that of
course is the film that has that of
course is the story about those Wild
West shows I spoke about last week and
it the episode he dramatizes actually
involves a comical and also very
disturbing confrontation or interaction
between great chief Sitting Bull and a
drunken Buffalo Bill and then and that
and an absolutely corrupt drunken
morally muddled
Indian hero the played by incidentally
played by Paul Newman who had played you
know upright upright heroes frequently
before and let me jump down a little bit
and say one word the films I've listed
from 88 on are our more recent films all
of them relative successes my view is
that his greatest work is in the 70s but
these later films I've listed are
interesting but I wanted to say a word
about Tanner and Tanner on Tanner
because they show how imaginative and
experimental he remained even in his
later years as a director as some of you
may know Tanner is not a movie it was a
television series and it was a very
interesting television series in which
we could see Robert Altman further
developing this interest he had in this
confusion between reality and fiction he
he see III think he was he was right
about this in some ways he felt that I
mean partly I think he felt that that
because we live in such a media
saturated culture the difference and
because of the power that celebrity
seems to exercise in our culture this
celebrity was always one of often one of
Robert Altman's subplots it's a key
subject in in in in Nashville and he
returns to it you know in a number of
his later films as well
the trick of Tanner is that it purports
to be a documentary following a
presidential a Democratic presidential
candidate in the Democratic primaries of
what 1988 and he and and he got an actor
of one of his favorite actors he
actually has a the act of this actor I
think his name is Michael Murphy he has
a role in McCabe and mrs. Miller he's
one of the he's the younger company
representative who comes near the end of
the film to negotiate with McCabe about
selling his interest in the town and
he's a wonderful actor this guy Michael
Murphy and like many of the actors who
appear in Altman's films you have a
sense if you've watched Altman's films
over your over the whole of his career
that there was a repertory company that
kept coming back to work with him again
and again Elliott Gould must be in six
or seven of his movies Michael Murphy
and at least three or four
he has favorite actresses too who loved
to work with them and Julie Christie is
one the star of tonight's film Warren
Beatty is another of his favorite actors
although Beatty was such a big star that
could generate his own films he didn't
need Altman as much as some of these
others actors did in any case what's the
trick of Tanner the strategy of Tanner
the really memorable thing about that or
it was a I think a very significant
television event is that it is that the
fictional Tanner played by this guy
Michael Murphy who treated with complete
seriousness I mean we mostly saw him
through the eyes of his press managers
his press handlers so there was a great
cynicism about the political process and
the gossip of the journalists about the
presidential canon but the real genius
of Tanner was that we saw Tanner on the
stump with the real presidential
candidates and they cooperated the real
presidential candidates cooperated in
the making of the film and there are
actually scenes in which the fictional
Tanner gets into a conversation with
Michael Dukakis who's who's also running
to be President there and and then
there's an interview with Michael
Dukakis in which Michael Dukakis
assesses the danger that that Tanner
represents to his candidacy so what what
what and when he returned to Tanner on
Tanner in 2004 he elaborated this theory
when that now Tanner is a retired
politician and he's helping his daughter
who's a documentary filmmaker do a new
political film but now it's about the
contemporary the the it was about the
the last election but the the last did
nomination the the nomination just I
guess it was the the first Bush election
was what it was about and it's very
interesting he brings back many of the
characters well both of these texts like
some of his other films are really
preoccupied with the question of this of
the blurred boundaries between what we
between the fictional worlds we live in
and the actual worlds we eat and breathe
in and the extent to which our media
saturated culture has created a kind of
virtual reality that we watch on
television and now of course we watch on
our computer screens that competes
the actual reality we live every day
well Altman loved playing games with
that question raising questions about it
and and and the first Tanner series is
among other things a powerful meditation
on the mendacity and the stupidity of
the political process in our country it
showed people trying to raise money
candidates scrambling to get five
minutes in front of the in front of the
news cameras just just at the moment
when the evening news is going to break
that sort of thing but very wonderfully
accurate cynical account of American
politics well let me turn now to McCabe
and mrs. Miller and try to concretize
some of what I've been saying with
specific reference to this remarkable
film ruling the sacred truths a line
that I that I have plagiarized from the
Yale literary critic and scholar Harold
Bloom who uses it to describe the
enterprise of certain Romantic poets who
are said to aim to whose aim was said in
blooms terms to be to ruin the inherited
truths of the society to attack them to
assault them and in a certain sense one
could say that that's Altman's ambition
as well to ruin to expose to undermine
to drench in irony the sacred truths
that have come down to us from cinematic
tradition and maybe from our political
and moral culture as well and we can see
this in many different aspects of of
Altman's of Altman's movie uh of many of
his films we feel these pressure these
elements but especially powerfully and
especially clearly I think in McCabe and
mrs. Miller one might say in fact that
the whole energy of McCabe and mrs.
Miller the whole energy of the film
resides in a kind of tension or clash
between the conventional expectations
that we have about westerns and even the
conventional expectations as they have
been complicated by the serious and
enlarging and already ironic westerns of
the late 50s and early 60s a kind of
tension or class between the
expectations we have about traditional
westerns no matter how ironic they might
have been
and the gritty comical Uggla fied and
humanized reality that Altman actually
presents us with and almost every
element of the film has this kind of
shock of recognition in it let's take
the question watch watch for example how
the film how the film treats both the
soundtrack and what you visually see one
of the thing when the film first came
out some reviewers complained that they
had trouble making out the dialogue and
they weren't lying about this it's
because when Altman takes his camera
inside and inside the dingy saloon in
which some of the action early in the
film begins and to which it returns
periodically as the film goes on Altman
does not tamp down the ambient noise in
the bar you hear the conversation of
other people you hear bodies moving you
hear various kinds of noise and
sometimes if if the people who are in
the foreground of the frame are talking
in very low voices their voices are
blotted out by the sounds around them
and in fact Altman's treatment of sound
all the way through the film has an has
a an energetic realism in it and it's a
it's a strange and ultimately I think
very satisfying aspect of the film the
way in which Altman seems to try to
create a grittier more accurate account
of the way sound operates in our world
and the fact is when when when we're in
in actuality and we address someone in a
crowded room it's not quiet the only
thing you can hear a lot of other thing
Altman wants to sort of recreate that
and sometimes it almost seems as if that
tendency that that aggressive tendency
that I've said is characteristic of
Altman's imagination may even be
expressing itself in the way he uses the
soundtrack because it's almost as if he
sucked the soundtrack may sometimes be
more interested in the words or sounds
coming from the margins of the frame
rather than from the center of the frame
so there are these elements of potential
distraction that you always have to
contend with when you're watching
Altman's film Altman's films the same
thing in a from another angle could also
be said to be true in some degree of the
way
the images work in the film watch
especially for the for the color palette
that Altman uses he plays around with
light and dark with certain kinds of
with with a certain kind of cold dark
damp feeling and he contrasts that with
a kind of lighting that that suggests
not not not incredibly bright sunlight
but a kind of nostalgic golden sunset
kind of imagery and and if you watch if
you watch the film in the very beginning
of the film one of the things that
happens is that sometimes this gold and
sort of light appears indoors and the
outdoors seemed gloomy and dank and dark
and then later in the film this this
this division between light and dark
undergoes an alteration you might ask
yourself why in one of the most dramatic
moments toward the end of the film there
is a a group of murderers and assassins
sort of a ride into the town and they
ride in accompanied by this kind of bed
with its Sun behind them accompanied by
this sort of golden haze that Altman has
ironically associated with with comfort
and and and and pleasure earlier earlier
in the film so both in terms of the
sound and the image we we we're engaged
in something new here and maybe I also
could in considering the word image I
should also mention Altman's montage
Altman's habits of editing he's capable
of the most fluid and and undistracted
editing if he wants to do it but he is
actually fonder of forms of editing that
are abrupt that are disconcerting that
are mildly disorienting and that style
is part I don't mean he does this at all
moments of the film but that style I
think is part or sometimes he'll whose
abrupt cuts that style is part of his of
his art I think but it's also part of
this sort of desire not to have things
too smooth not to have things to meet
his love of them his love of the inn of
the apparently imperfect is part of what
is part of what's operating there
and even a third element of what I'm
calling his special or his new realism
might have to do even with the way he
treats not just the physical spaces that
you see but even the weather watch how
lousy the weather it's in this film and
how much damage it does to people what
an unpleasant thing the weather actually
it snow really matters in this film bad
weather really matters in this film it
affects the outcome of the plot in
certain ways as you'll see so in it so
so this this this Missi realism I'm
talking about even extends to the way in
which the film treats the weather as you
as you'll as you'll see as the film as
the film proceeds the central features
of the traditional Western the hero
savior figure the protagonist figure the
gal from the east who is often a
schoolmarm who falls in love with the
hero and the idea that the Western as a
text as I've said many times already is
always a kind of founding story about
the creation of a community all of those
conventional structures remain in McCabe
and mrs. Miller but they're inverted
they're weird
let's take free let me just a quick
example the the character played by
Warren Beatty he said he really is in
some sense the founder of the town
there's a miserable mining not even him
it's a mining camp it just has a saloon
in it when the film opens and McCabe
arrives he's the great gambler that he's
actually a visionary entrepreneur in a
certain way although in a very ironic
sense and the story is it ironic
entrepreneurs story a Horatio Alger
story this this gambler McCabe comes to
town looks the place over Gamble's for a
while with these poor with these poor
schlubs who are suffering on the very
margins of civilization and then goes
away and when he comes back he's
bringing prostitutes with him this town
is not built by noble intentions it's
built by a whoremonger who brings a
bunch of prostitutes into the town and
sets up the town's first house of
prostitution and in fact McCabe becomes
the biggest landowner and the richest
man in town not because not because he
has the entrepreneurial vision of an
Andrew Carnegie although actually if we
closely at Andrew Carnegie's life we
might find he more resembles McCabe than
his biographers have acknowledged right
but in other words it's as if what McKay
what what Altman is doing is he's
telling a kind of ironic or mocking or
anti heroic Horatio Alger story right
and a well and as the story unfolds
something certain lovely things begin to
happen one thing that begins to happen
is we begin to see a soft or a aura or a
vulnerable side to make it to the McCabe
character and when the schoolmarm from
the east figure arrives she's really
from the east she's not even from the
East of the United States she has an
English accent right it's Julie Christie
but she's not a schoolmarm she's a
retired [ __ ] who was now who was now a
manager of [ __ ] she's a she she's a
she's a [ __ ] mistress an expert in
running [ __ ] and in fact what soon as
she arrives in town and partners with
McCabe McCabe really begins to make
money and what we begin to realize is
McCabe really doesn't know what he's
doing McCabe had a kind of vision but he
doesn't really even know and there's a
wonderful scene over over a over a meal
in which the Julie Christie character
who will stand her food like some John
Wayne character while the McCabe
characters looks very askance at her
well there's a scene in which did the
Julie Christine in effect explains to
McCabe how little he knows about how to
take care of management and then what
develops is a kind of love affair
between McCabe and this and this
prostitute and and what one begins to
realize this first of all the woman is
much smarter than the man and you can
see her despair being generated as the
story unfolds and McCabe is manipulated
by other people
she knows the powerful forces that
McCabe will be up against by the end of
the film and she tries to discourage him
and help him but he's too caught up in
his sort of macho idea of what a man is
to allow himself to see the wisdom of
what she's saying and he's actually
sometimes embarrassed by the fact that
she seems to know more than she more
than he does
well the relation between McCabe and
mrs. Miller inverts the normal love
affair relationship it shows us a woman
who's stronger and smarter although also
much more cynical and despairing than
her man
but McCabe's optimism and sense of
self-confidence which he loses pretty
quickly is shown in the film to be able
to be a function of his ignorance and
his innocence so so the treatment of the
love story and the treatment of the hero
savior figure in the film is deeply
humanizing and deeply ironic there are
actually more credible psychologically
complex characters these two McCabe and
mrs. Miller than most of their
predecessors in earlier westerns but
there are also deeply ironic embodiments
of their much nobler ancestors and the
same thing is that I've just been saying
about about the hero and the heroine
about the love story and the Savior
story is also true of the founding myth
itself the name of this town is
Presbyterian Church very good name isn't
it and it takes its name from the
steeple of an unfinished church and I
think the allusion to unfinished
churches in earlier traditional westerns
is certainly intentional it takes this
name from the unfinished to [ __ ] from
this from the unfinished Church in the
in the town and in fact as you will see
the church is never finished you might
watch how in the plaque that works out
and why it works out and what role the
church and especially the minister who
is hanging out at the church plays in
the outcome of the story does the church
does implicitly therefore does religion
play a constructive or a destructive
role in the film
I'm not giving too much as a way to tell
you it's obvious it's obvious which
answer is appropriate it plays a
destructive role just as its hostile to
certain political myths about the
founding of the weapon's West the film
is also hostile to our piety z' and
complacency is about the role of
religious institutions in our and
especially in the founding of our
society so watch how it works itself out
and how the and how that traditional
icon of the of the conventional Western
has its meanings and its significance
inverted and subverted yeah in in this
in this film there's one
crucial film conventional Western to
which this film directly alludes I think
or at least implicitly directly alludes
one what it alludes to other films as
well but there's one especially them and
and I want to show you a show you a clip
from it because it has its own
distinction and it reminds you about the
not only about the sort of valid
dimensions of the Western but the but
how stylized and and heroic in a certain
way the conventional Western is and only
you give it it'll be a it'll be a nice
contrast with the anti-heroic qualities
of McCabe and mrs. Miller and this is a
scene from from the very beginning of a
film made in the early 50s called High
Noon starring the traditional the most
iconic the the first or second most
iconic of Western heroes if John Wayne
was the first then Gary Cooper was the
second and this stars Gary Cooper but
the main reason I want you to see the
film see this opening of the film is
because it's very important to McCabe
and mrs. Miller and there's no doubt
that Altman expects his audience not
only to be thinking about many prior
westerns to contrast with what happens
in this Western but he certainly expects
his audience to remember specifically
the beginning of High Noon and the way
High Noon plays itself out know and
perhaps perhaps also certain other
westerns play maybe as significant
almost as significant a role in the film
but it's but but High Noon especially
and the main reason that High Noon is so
important to McCabe and mrs. Miller is
that it's also a drama that takes place
in the physical spaces of the town High
Noon is begins brilliantly with bad guys
riding into town and and and in we
hardly see the hero until the final
images of the sequence I'm going to show
you the Gary Cooper figure bad guy man a
man's been released from prison who's
going to take vengeance on the town
marshal it's the day of the town
marshals wedding when the bad guys are
coming into town to take their revenge
the film itself incidentally is a
parable of the McCarthy era of the early
1950s it's even like many westerns we've
talked about this like many westerns
disguised form of social and political
commentary on the present and in this
case the the marshals endangered a lot
of bad guys are coming after him he goes
around the town asking for help to set
up a posse to help him defend the town
nobody wants to help him he's left on
his own and he has to fight against
these guys on his own right that's that
so and the drama of the film has to do
with this where it's and at and as
you'll see McCabe and mrs. Miller ends
on a similar note in which McCabe is up
against a force of men far larger than
he he and also professional killers
right and in that sense the end of
McCabe in which McCabe has to be the
lost the whole last section of McCabe
which involves McCabe defending himself
against assassins who have been
dispatched by a corporation that has
tried to buy McCabe out and when he's
refused to sell they said okay we'll
take another route well eliminate him
right
this so Altman's telling the story of
capitalism at its most at its most
aggressively evil right instead of the
kind of fairy tales that were told about
how the West was made by by a certain
mythological optimistically mythological
westerns so so what when when McCabe
defends himself at the very end against
these larger forces one of the things
that gives him an advantage and one of
the most interesting moments in the
passages in the film occurs here has to
do with his knowledge of the town he
helped build the town so he knows every
nook and cranny of the town and he's
able in part to hold his own against
four other men who are actually much
better with with violence than he is
because of his knowledge of the town
something of that same kind of thing
happens at the end of High Noon the
beginning of High Noon is exciting
because what it shows is the film is
exploring the territory that it would
later return to so so I'm showing it to
you because I think in part it's
interesting it's a nice contrast there's
no question that Altman expects us to
have this film in our minds when we're
watching the cave okay
any of you recognize us after things
we've included this ruler and then the
Spaghetti Westerns David he started yeah
he was first he began to might have less
ego cavities
but he's an actor was associated with
evil roles in a series of westerns the
singer is Tex Ritter
I also wanted you to see this beginning
so you could hear this ballad and
contrasted with Leonard Cohen's stoned
area Leonard Cohen
sounds like he's singing out of the
counterculture and what what's the
different subject matter
only someone who had never seen a movie
would fail to recognize that these are
bad guys now how do you know they're bad
guys they're unshaven they have black
hats right there's a kind of implicit
symbolism that the conventional Western
even subtle ones like this one which is
a grown up Western it's an adult Western
still make use of Altman will throw all
those kinds of markers out he thinks
they're foolish another church
that's heavy handed
so you see how what's happening here is
a kind of visit through the town it
isn't until later in the film that you
realize that every space you go by
should have registered with you because
the later action of the film will take
place on these streets in these in these
barns on these balconies
now watch this shovel and there's Gary
Cooper who will be our hero and in fact
he's marrying Grace Kelly who in this
film is a Quaker and guess what one of
the climactic events in the film in vote
is the Quaker lady fires a gun to save
her beloved violates her moral
principles and kills someone to save her
man okay now I don't want I don't want
you to think that my can we have the
lights again Greg I don't want you to
think that I'm suggesting that High Noon
is not a remarkable movie it is it's
what it is it's one of the very very
good westerns it it has great subtlety
and power in its own way but I think
that Altman definitely wanted us to
think about the radical differences
between the universe imagined in McCabe
and mrs. Miller and the world as it's
imagined in even even subtle adult 50s
westerns so many of these things are
crystallized for us in the remarkable
conclusion of the film and I hope that
you'll pay a lot of attention to that
it's an extended sequence and it's it's
a it operates according to a principle
of parallel action the church I
mentioned earlier catches fire watch why
it catches fire it's connected to the
plot and while the church is burning
most of the town gets together in a kind
of comic bucket brigade to put this to
put the fire out they are partly aided
by a new fire engine a mark of the
town's growth right that arrives at a
certain point in the history of the town
the fire engine I believe arrives at the
same time that mrs. Miller arrives in
town they're both equally important
historical events for the town's future
but the arrival of the engine suggests
of the coming of civilization right and
there's a certain sense in which the act
that the the the fighting of the of the
fire it's actually almost treated like a
slapstick event
real film buffs would actually recognize
visual illusions or references to the
Keystone Cops era I don't want to
exaggerate this but you'll see it I mean
there actually is someone carrying a
bucket that has a hole in it
waters falling and that kind of thing
and they're incredibly ineffectual in
there trying to put out the fire I don't
think they succeed very well the church
essentially is destroyed or at least the
steeple is destroyed but what happens
nonetheless is the town has come
together and it's actually a moment in
which you actually feel that the town's
identity is being forged as these
disparate people the [ __ ] and the
barbers and the respectable people in
the saloonkeeper
all get together to try to put the fire
out so it is a moment in which the town
is really aborning right while that is
happening McCabe is being stalked by the
assassins the creator of the town the
founder of the town is you know in a
fight for his life while there while
this slapstick firefighting is going on
watch how that works itself out watch
out and then pay a special attention to
the profound disturbing ambiguities of
the ending one of the reasons I admire
McCabe and mrs. Miller so much is that
it seems in many ways to satisfy the
desires one has the desire one has for
the trappings of a conventional Western
they are all to all of the elements that
you think of should that you think
should belong to a serious Western are
present but they're present in such
ironies such damage such inverted form
that they make you rethink not only
those particular conventions but the
larger mythological and ideological work
that Western that the Western mythology
has performed an American society up to
this time so it makes McCabe and mrs.
Miller not just a wonderfully
entertaining film it's full of comic
moments and brilliant performances it is
in its own right and a a great work of
imaginative intelligence but it is an
even larger thing it seems to me because
of the intelligence with which it
engages in this systematic conversation
with its aesthetic and moral ancestry in
the great founding story of the Western
which I suppose must be identified as
America's most distinctive
in some ways most disturbingly revealing
story about itself
you